[Musique]
georges tron démissionne de son mandat
de maire de
décision douloureuse écrit-il condamné
en appel en février à cinq ans de prison
dont trois ferme pour viol sur une
collaboratrice il continuer de gérer la
municipalité depuis sa cellule de la
prison de la santé est l'une de ses
campagnes c'était de m'accuser d'avoir
avec un point d'interrogation d'ailleurs
était le patient zéro qui avait
communiqué à l'équipe britannique qui
elle cohabite quinze jours après après
moi voyez dernière en mars d'être le
patient zéro et un jour barry johnson me
dis je raconte ça dans le livre pourrait
alors c'est toi qui nous a communiqué le
co vide au jury peut-être que c'est le
contraire donc chappuis s'est arrêté là
ton corps c'est un coup tordu en italie
trois jours après le terrible accident
de téléphérique qui a fait 14 morts à
stresa trois personnes ont été arrêtées
le propriétaire du téléphérique et deux
responsables du site ils sont soupçonnés
d'avoir volontairement désactivé le
système de freinage d'urgence de la
cabine après un premier problème de
maintenance le 26 avril et ce pour des
raisons purement économiques
la société qui gère le téléphérique a
été fragilisé financièrement par les
différents confinement elle espérait une
bonne saison estivale et faire les
travaux à l'automne c'est un pari qui a
coûté la vie à 14 personnes dimanche
dernier il aurait assisté les
manifestations de policiers
je ne prends pas vous ne croyez pas non
je vous me posez la question je vous
réponds je ne crois pas officieusement
l'entourage du président à nous d'y et
qu' il serait furax j'entends que
matignon et l'elysée seraient concernés
par cette plainte de monsieur darmanin
twitte le socialiste boris vallot oui
c'est consternant et ça relève de
l'intimidation dit il surtout et les
faits l'ont montré pourquoi il
s'agissait de mettre en oeuvre au fond
police justice nous avons besoin dans ce
pays d'une police forte est une justice
forte qui travaillent main dans la main
deux nouvelles plaintes visant patrick
poivre d'arvor viennent d'être déposées
l'une pour viol l'autre pour agression
sexuelle
23 millions de français ont reçu une
première dose 10 millions les deux
injections
malgré ces chiffres encourageants
l'académie de médecine souhaité rendre
la vaccination obligatoire
une préconisation plutôt bien accueilli
et pourquoi il nous causerait pas une
étoile jaune pour k
soit repérer plus facilement comme quand
même agnès buzyn qui est maintenant
protégée en suisse n'a pas payé ses
crimes
l'académie suggère également
l'obligation vaccinale pour des
professions dites essentielles comme
pour les enseignants les policiers ou
les soignants l'étoile jaune a conduit
femmes enfants vieillards aux fours
crématoires
il n'avait pas le choix on a le choix
pour le vaccin alors vraiment ferme là
bien ta grande gueule réfléchit avant de
parler donc moi je ne fais que répéter
un bien évidemment le gouvernement de
s'exprimer à chaque fois que jean marie
bigard bout un coup trop et prononce des
insultes et des menaces
je pense à ça illustre vraiment les
ravages de l'alcoolisme enfin pardon de
le dire mais moi je suis étonné dans les
commentaires que personne ne fasse
référence à l'image d'un ambassadeur de
marque un pour la campagne de
vaccination anti copie de regarder le
sait le champion du monde français qui n
aiment pas p pour certains ces photos
sont fausses et ce n'est même pas une
map et dessus après les théories
fumeuses
il y a les blagues non ce n'est pas non
plus un statut de cire devant la maison
blanche
le geste est hautement symbolique un an
après la mort de john jeu floyd la
famille était reçue par joe biden s'est
l'intro de tous les films mgm pour metro
goldwin meyer depuis 10 924
c'est la grosse majeur à hollywood yens
elle vient d'être officiellement racheté
par amazon qui vient de lâcher 8,4
milliards de dollars
j'ai parlé avec les négociateurs du
congrès j'espère que quelque temps après
cette journée de commémoration nous
parviendrons à trouver un accord sur le
projet de loi georges floquet
je regarde derrière les verrières